be a doll and get your mother a large  forties from Tony's there's no money in  here you pay for it Donna  I know you're making money  let's do this what do you see your  nightmare was a gala for you would you  like that okay good news I got another  job this guy he's got at least 300 K is  he blind that's kind of messed up to  have a blind guy isn't it  just cuz he's blind don't mean he's the  same bro there's gotta be a piece of  cake store you those some girl I know  heard this guy's daughter daughter dies  and this rich ass family pays him off  God is an army vet loner are we good  he's out he's a sleeping beauty nice  and then he's in the house it's all the  way in there why'd you bring a gun  who's there okay man just chill I stay  right there that's me  then it's me I messed up real bad  now you see what I see  that was May 10 forever please